Incremental concept learning
is intimately connected with
human cognition.
We can adopt two views of learning.
In one view of learning,
the intelligent agent is given
with a large number of examples.
The agent's task, then, is to detect
patterns of regularity in those examples
and learn those patterns of regularity.
In the alternative view, the agent
is given one example at a time.
And the agent has to gradually,
incrementally learn concepts
out of those examples.
Now you and I as agents,
as cognitive agents in our daily lives,
deal with one example at a time.
Rarely is it that we
encounter millions or
hundreds of thousands of
examples given at once.
Incremental concept learning is
a lot closer than kind of learning
that you and I as cognitive agents do.